Newly released video
shows the former
President Trump
during an August deposition
with the New York attorney
general's office.
Trump was deposed
as part of the attorney general
Letitia James
civil investigation
to the Trump
organization's business practices.
Former president invoked the fifth
more than 400 times
and declined to answer the question.
That declined to answer the question.
Same answer.
Same. Exact same.
Same answer. Same. Same.
Same same answer.
Same answer.
That was in the deposition.
The former President Trump
also took swipes
at his former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen.
Letitia James relied on the testimony
of Michael Cohen,
a convicted felon and liar.
This is the witness, a stone cold loser
the real loser that she used to justify
her obsessive
work.
So Cohen is a key figure
in several investigations in New York.
AG's investigation
into Trump
started after Cohen testified
to Congress in 2019.
And when he said this
it was my experience that Mr.
Trump inflated his total assets
when it served his purposes
and deflated his assets
to reduce his real estate taxes.
So here in Manhattan,
the district attorney has convened
a grand jury
to present evidence
in a revamped investigation to the effort
to stop Stormy Daniels from going public
about an alleged affair with Trump.
Cohen facilitated the payments
and was reimbursed
by the Trump Organization.
He pleaded guilty to nine
federal charges,
including campaign finance violations,
and was sentenced
to three years in prison.
Here's what Trump said in 2018
about the payment
Trump's former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen joins me now.
He is the author of the book Revenge
you can buy it now
and he is here to discuss
what is going on.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate you joining us.
Listen, first of all,
let me get your
I want to get your response
to the deposition that you just saw here
pleading the fifth more than 400 times.
It's expected.
I mean,
Donald
cannot keep track
of the lies that he tells.
And so what better way
than to stop a fool
from being deposed
and hurting himself
further than to tell him
to plead the Fifth at least 400 times?
So, listen,
this new this
not shouldn't be a new investigation,
but would you call it
a revamped investigation?
What would you how would you describe it?
Let's say reinvigorated. Reinvigorated.
So your role in the Stormy Daniels
payments, right.
You call it the hush money payment.
Remind our viewers what your role was.
So I was contacted by David Pecker
in regard to Stormy Daniels.
She then
and that goes back into early
the 2011 period.
But then again,
right before the election, I was
then asked by Donald to handle it
with Allen Weisselberg.
And what that really meant for me
was to resolve it. And so I did.
But I did it at the direction of
and for the benefit of Donald J. Trump.
David Pecker was the Enquirer.
That's correct.
Weisselberg
is the CFO of the Trump Organization,
which has has faced repercussions for
and is now sitting in Rikers Island.
There you go.
Okay, so this
a lot of this is centered on u
this reinvigorated investigation
that you talk about.
How were you contacted
and what happened when you
with your interactions with
the DA's office?
So I had dealt with the DEA
13 times prior to my most recent
revisit to the DEA,
my first time
under the break administration.
They contacted me most recently.
They asked for
my cell phones
because they want to be able to
extract from it
the voice recordings
that I had had
with Keith Davidson,
former attorney
to Stormy Daniels
before Michael Avenatti,
as well as a bunch
of emails, text messages and so on.
That way you could be used as evidence
if in fact that they proceed forward,
which I would suspect they are.
Well, you turned over
a lot of information
in the initial need
because they searched your home
and you didn't turn it over.
I was raided by the FBI they took it.
All right.
So this is new stuff
that you turned over to.
It's the same stuff,
but it's new to the district attorney.
They've seen some of it,
but now they're in full possession of it.
Okay.
People are wondering why
Donald Trump is not face
any sort of repercussions for you.
Went to prison he did not.
How do you view this investigation?
What is his culpability here?
Do you think that
he will face consequences
for this investigation?
I've said all along that
I thought the DA's case is by far
the simplest to prove
and it
is the most destructive
to Donald Trump individually and
to his business as well.
I do believe that he will
see repercussions
for the first time
in almost his entire life.
We've seen quite a few cases now,
whether it's
Weisselberg's incarceration,
whether it's the 17
counts against the Trump Organization,
and now with the attorney general's case
I think we're going to see
a lot of repercussion.
Why do you believe that
and what does that look like?
Well,
remember, the attorney general's case
is civil in nature,
and people
make the constant mistake of 250 million.
That's the base
that they're talking about.
That's not the max.
I think it'll be more in the neighborhood
of 700 million.
Based upon at least the information
that I know.
700 million. What?
What do you mean in terms of fines?
$17 in fines.
That's correct.
That's what
I think
that's James's case
will ultimately demonstrate.
Why should anyone believe Michael Cohen?
Michael Cohen is a convicted felon.
Yes, that's true.
And I was convicted
because the former president got
his pecker pulled by a porn star.
I was directed to go ahead
and to pay the hush money payments,
which I was reimbursed.
I'm the only one that suffered
And in my book,
I go into great lengths
about the improper prosecution
that I received
was 48 hours,
that either
you plead guilty or we file
a 80 page indictment
that includes your wife.